Bon et bien nous avons ici une quarantaine de salles de classe pour 500 élèves, parfaitement autonomes.
à qui nous assurons simplement connaissances et soutiens.
C'est une super école hein !
L'ambiance y est vraiment agréable, les profs sont super souples.
Moi si j'ai intégré la FAP c'est avant tout pour pratiquer, m'entourer de professionnels
développer mes acquis .
Moi c'est pour baiser des meufs.
Plein
Alors moi c'est mon père qui a voulu que je suive ce cursus.
(soupir) J'trouve pas mon bleu là
Et bien, je dirait qu’aujourd’hui la FAP c'est la meilleure école pour étudier la pornographie.
De l'érotisme soft au trash/hardcore
Oh non !
Non putain non !
Dégueulasse !
Atila ?
-Présent !
Tabata ?
(chuchote) Hey psst!
Tu pourras donner ça à Cynthia s'il te plait
A Cynthia ? Ouai j'là baise à 15 heure pour le cours de Lantru
Ah cool t'es un pote.
Roberto ! Je vous dérange pas ?
J'espère au moins que vous parlez de cul.
Mon cours préféré ?
Euh...
C'est peut-être parce que je suis un peu un cérébral mais hmm
Définitivement...
Les cours de scénarios !
*silence*
Et bien ça va peut-être vous surprendre mais moi je suis plutôt cours pratique
*simulation d'orgasme*
Oui c'est nôtre spécificité d'offrir en plus des cours théoriques, des cours purement pratiques.
Pour mieux appréhender le milieu du travail après les études.
Bon les filles vous attachez vos cheveux
et vous mettez vos lunettes
Si il y a des deuxième années, oubliez les lunettes
Si je devais dire un dernier mot : *dérape sur le sol*
Et bien simplement que nos inscriptions commencent le mois prochain
et que nous sommes impatients de vous voir à la FAP
Et surtout ne vous inquiétez pas ! Ici ce n'est pas la taille qui compte
c'est le diplôme !
La FAP :
Jamais faire du hard n'a été aussi ..... Easy